I've said before and I even said
yesterday when we were talking about the
recent shooting in parkland Florida that
when President Obama was president of
the United States right after the Sandy
Hook school shooting we had 85 to 90
percent support for universal background
checks and we still didn't get them so
I'm skeptical about whether we're going
to get them now but what we did get
during the Obama presidency was an Obama
era rule that made it just a tiny bit
more difficult for people with suspected
mental illness to buy a gun the law
wasn't even put in place until December
of 2016 the last full month of President
Obama's presidency then you might be
saying well David David why are you
bringing up something that was made law
in December of 2016 the reason I'm
bringing it up is that Trump himself has
been saying almost exclusively after
shootings that the problem is not the
guns themselves in fact he often will
not even mention guns when he talks
after a shooting about that shooting
Trump has been insisting that the
problem is mental illness but you'll
recall that from very early on in
Trump's presidency Trump revoked the law
that was passed while President Obama
was president that made it more
difficult for people with suspected
mental illness to get guns so let's take
it step-by-step
Trump pointed to mental illness as the
real problem with guns many times he
minimizes shootings by Americans and
white dudes as they're just deranged
nuts and he did it after this week's
shooting as well I showed you this tweet
yesterday remember that Donald Trump
tweeted so many signs that the Florida
shooter was mentally disturbed even
expelled from school for bad and erratic
behavior neighbors and classmates knew
he has a bit he was a big problem must
always report such instances to
authorities again and again yesterday
Trump made his first public comments
after the shooting he made a brief set
of prepared remarks and he said he is
going to focus on the problem of mental
health not of guns he's got a tackle
mental health issues which is the kind
of thing you say about homework you're
gonna tackle your homework yes you know
like I don't know if this problem is
that simple it's not
but Donald Trump has been making it very
clear that guns are not going to be what
he addresses it's going to be so-called
mental health well it turns out that in
Donald Trump's second month in office he
repealed President Obama's law that
expanded mental health considerations
for gun background checks the law that
President Obama was able to pass added
people who were receiving Social
Security for mental illness as well as
people who were deemed unfit to handle
their own finances to the national
background check database the logic of
it was okay if you're so disabled by
mental illness that you're getting
Social Security benefits for it maybe
you shouldn't have a gun and Trump
nullified that law just weeks into his
presidency yet he's now telling us the
problem is mental illness and we've got
to prevent mentally ill people from
getting guns of course when Trump did
this in February of last year
the NRA cheered it now I know it
wouldn't actually have prevented this
week's shooting right there wasn't
anything in the shooters background that
would have prevented him from getting
this ar-15 style rifle that he used
anyway but at what point can we hold
people accountable for legislating the
opposite of what they claim to want
right this is an example of why it
doesn't matter what Trump's true beliefs
are what matters is how he will
legislate because we've talked about how
Trump has talked a lot about higher
American and all this stuff but in his
business life he always hires foreign
workers at his resorts we've talked
about how it doesn't really matter
whether Trump is actually pro-life or
just pretending right now we know he was
pro-choice for like his first 68 or 69
years of his life two years ago all of a
sudden he's pro-life right before he
runs for president even if we don't
believe it if Trump will kowtow to the
March for life as he did if he's going
to talk about and try to restrict
abortion that's what matters and it's
the exact same thing with guns whatever
it is that Trump has said in the past
including being critical of the NRA it
doesn't matter because what Trump is
saying now as president Trump is what's
actually going to impact policy and it
just so happens that
is also doing the opposite of what he
claims to want saying that mental
illness is the problem and not the guns
but he also made it easier in February
of 2017 for people with mental illness
to get those guns very very dangerous
stuff and listen I just want the
hypocrisy to end that's really what I
want here send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show